hey guys Ryan Wright is here so today
I'm gonna be checking out the new
trailer that just dropped for one of the
top 5 for me one of the top 5 most
anticipated films of the year
Tomorrowland loved director Brad Bird I
see that this movie is rated PG I
haven't looked forward to a PG movie in
this long let's check it out
sequences of sci-fi action violence and
peril somatic elements of language
anything's possible
and then it was gone where you want I
want you to take me to the place I saw
when I touched this where'd you get that
I know that you were there who are you
kid
George Clooney to the rescue
good idea
you ain't seen nothing yeah
we wanted to see Tomorrowland here it
comes
see that I keep putting this out man a
lot of good trailers erect nipples right
there you see that
wow what a cool-looking trailer huh I
like how that trailer showed us like
that one scene part of me is like I wish
I didn't just give away that whole scene
but you know I like seeing that because
I wasn't expecting to feel such a level
of intensity
I forgot that Brad Bird can really do
that is really not just make a fun
action adventure but he knows how to
make it intense at the same time
I love how colorful it looks I love how
imaginary it is I love a good science
fiction fantasy I like it when both of
those genres come together George
Clooney looks like he's not just playing
George Clooney this time around I feel
like he's actually doing a character you
know he does do characters but he's
normally like mr. cool George Clooney
he's like kind of the old scientist guy
in this one and I like seeing that
Britney Robertson or Robinson I forgot
to say her last name
she's [ __ ] cute dude she's really
cute like wow Tomorrowland
more like vagina the effects look cool I
like how it's not showing us too much of
Tomorrowland the trailers are making us
go what is Tomorrowland I want to see
more of Tomorrowland so it was kind of
cool that they showed us a lot of before
they go there but they're not showing us
too much of when they're actually there
it's a great tease I hope the trailers
continue to not give away too much
because I'm already really excited to
see this I'm already intrigued by the
mystery of it all it looks like it's
gonna be a fantastic adventure I like
how it feels like an intense adventure
and it doesn't rely on like violence or
a lot of bad language or something you
know like they were okay with making it
PG and it looks like it could be like
one of the best family films of the year
anyway guys thanks for mentioning that
was out and really stoked to see this
movie if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter because I like people
following me on
than just YouTube it makes me feel
special
River fun to school named River [ __ ] you
go swimming a lot River hey what's up
guys just wanted to say I love your
channel I got hooked after looking for
your reviews on crimson peak and
honestly you are [ __ ] hilarious
no love your channel definitely keep up
the great work is it possible I could
get a shout out after all I am the 420th
like River Fantuz of course you can get
a shout out River is such a sexy name
dude let's see what you look like let's
see if you live up to the height look at
you man can't even see your face you're
like a mysterious badass looking off
into the mountains with really short
shorts they're showing too much skin in
your shorts man then oh you probably got
a big [ __ ] waiting to come out of those
shorts let rivers sperm flow upstream
you know what I mean
cream pie